bootstrap is the most popular css
framework and it makes it easier to
build great looking websites david
teaches this course and he has a bunch
of experience in bootstrap and even
helped create a popular bootstrap
library
hey youtube my name is david and today i
prepared for you a crash course for
bootstrap 5. so the most
common front-end framework used around
the world
i'm a co-founder of mdbootstrap.com
so i think
we are the one of the best people to
teach you that because what mdb is is
actually a material design connected
with bootstrap so we've created a open
source library where we actually use
bootstrap 5 and we've been doing this
for five years already uh we started
back in 2015 when the bootstrap 3 was
the current version then we migrated to
bootstrap 4 and now obviously we are
using bootstrap 5
so once you finish that crash course you
might be interested in checking this out
uh because as i said this is the library
where we decide to um connect material
design from google so the specific
design which comes from google apps uh
with the bootstrap so yeah we have a lot
of experience in that uh what we gonna
cover in this uh video uh what bootstrap
actually is uh just in a few words
because you're gonna see this on the
real examples then i'm gonna guide you
through the installation and the setup
so how to start working with it there
are gonna be a few ways how how you can
add the bootstrap to your project then
we're gonna cover the most important
part which is a grid system so
this would make bootstrap so famous and
we'll be also
using and learning how to use different
components and finally at the end of the
video i'm gonna show you how to build a
page from scratch using bootstrap so
what the bootstrap is a long story short
is the most popular front-end framework
around the globe now so let me give you
some numbers in 2013 bootstrap run 1.6
of top million sites then back in 2016
bootstrap ran already 15 percent in 2018
it was already 18 and nowadays it's more
than 20
uh around the globe so it's a huge
number it's a really really widely used
library and there is this um
page which is called bill with which
gives bootstrap a 72 percent of share of
the framework market so within all the
pages which are utilizing any frameworks
bootstrap has 72 percent of it so i
believe this is a good reason uh to know
bootstrap uh why should you use
bootstrap there are many many different
reasons why to do it but obviously
that increase your development speed so
if you use the existing components like
you've seen um on the screen before
you've gone just save a lot of time you
could create all of that by yourself but
there's no point because it's been
created for you and it's been tested by
the
millions of different developers um
responsiveness this is what made
bootstrap actually so famous so but now
it's obvious when you create a page it
has to be responsive but back in the
days in 2015 that wasn't that obvious
and bootstrap grid was the reversionary
tool which changed a lot in the web
development
obviously
when you are developer if you use
library that prevent you from repetition
so you don't write pretty much the same
code in a different way for different
projects
so that gives you that adds the
consistency to your project because just
reusing the same code
bootstrap takers of the browser
bootstrap takers about the browser
compatibility
and i think it has the one of the
largest community in the world so if you
have any issue with it or if you don't
know how to do it simply you know search
for it google for it or just ask
question on one of the one of the you
know facebook groups or or stack
overflow and then you're gonna get
answer very very quickly and finally uh
you can customize it to your needs so
these are the components which are there
and we will be going through most of
them so we're going to put our hands on
the keyboard and we're going to start
using them
so we're going to just
create something out of it so yeah i
mean without further ado let's jump into
installation
in order to install bootstrap we need to
navigate to getbootstrap.com
and you can already see that there are
um
multiple way on how you can install uh
bootstrap on how you can add bootstrap
to your project so you can already see
that you can use it with npm projects uh
you can also use cdn or you can simply
download it so i'm going to show you all
three options so let's start with the
download option so i'm going to hit a
download button that's going to direct
me to this page obviously it might look
a little bit different because bootstrap
is continuously updating the
documentation
however it should looks more like this
and
now once we are on the
download page let's hit this download
compile css and js and let's save it and
so that's gonna store it on my hard
drive and then let's go to this this
folder and let's unzip it
to the destination of our choice so i'm
gonna put it over here
let's wait a second to
unzip it so as you can see it will
contain css and
js
so let's um
actually let's leave it like this now
what i'm going to do i'm going to open
the
project in the visual studio code
okay and let's create a new file so i'm
going to hit
new file intex html and i'm gonna type
exclamation mark and press stop this is
what emmett does
if you are not familiar with amit please
check tutorials on that because i will
be using this uh i will also explain how
to do it but i strongly encourage you to
get familiar with it because this is
going to speed up your development and
actually
one way of doing of using or speeding up
this development is to use
it like this so instead of typing the um
the full formula for linking the css and
js i'm gonna just type link and press
stop and that's gonna give me this um
the stack uh pre-filled and i'm just
gonna say css slash and i'm gonna search
for bootstrap css file so that's gonna
load the css and the same for the body
uh for the gs um before the ending
body tag so i'm gonna type script
source and then hit tab and i'm gonna do
the same so js slash bootstrap
bootstrap
js
now if you want to load just the
bootstrap.js you need to
remember also to
um to install or to add popper if you
want to like if you want to use it
because
bootstrap depends on
on the popper js so you need to go to
proper js web page and then either
download it or or load it via cdn uh but
just to show you um
that it's working let's create h1 hello
bootstrap
word
and let's open this in with the live
server so this should open the browser
now
and it will
i can already see for those who are
familiar with bootstrap that the font
has changed already this is the default
bootstrap font but let's check the
console where we're gonna see that our
bootstrap has been actually loaded by
the way i've just opened this console
this is part of web developer tools
i did it with pressing a combination of
ctrl shift i
but you can also do it from here so
click on the menu those three
lines over here this hamburger so called
and then go to more tools than developer
tool so that's how you can open or and
close it and now we can see the error
here but this is regarding the valve
icon which browser tries to load so the
icon which is shown over here obviously
we don't have any so we can skip this
warning and now if we go to a network
tab and refresh our page again we're
gonna see uh all the requests which our
page is doing so obviously except for
the index html so the file itself the
html file which we just created we can
also see that bootstrap.css and
bootstrap.js has been unloaded
successfully now as i mentioned before
if we would like to use for example
popover
component which relies on proper
dependency we would have to
also add proper gs here so before
loading the bootstrap.js or there is the
other option so instead of loading
bootstrap
js
we can also
do it
by
loading the bundle so the bundle
contains all the dependencies right so
if you don't want to add a separate
dependency over here uh you can simply
load bundle instead now this is the
the most basic way of start using
bootstrap so by downloading the source
file now let's move to the the next
option
if you don't want to download and move
unzip files to your project manually
there is a faster way to do it so let's
see how we can start using bootstrap
using cdn
and then again there are two options so
here we we can have option with the
bundled js which
contains all the dependencies or we can
use
the separate option where we have the
bootstrap loaded separately and popper
as well so let's see how it works
um let's create a new folder here and
let's call it cdn
let's open this in
visual studio code let's create new file
index.html exclamation mark tab that's
going to create the basic structure and
now let's just copy
first the css and place it within our
head and now let's copy the bundled
version down below the body and then
again
let's add h1
um
hello world
cdn word let's say and let's open this
with v live server
and you can also see that this is
working fine let's open console to
verify refresh and we have bootstrap css
and
bootstrap bundle mean js
and as i mentioned
instead of this single line over here
we could also use two entries for the
uh popper and the bootstrap separately
so let's save it let's check whether
it's working fine
and now we can see that the popper is
being loaded separately
okay now let's move to the next
installation option
which is npm
so for those of you who are
creating your project with the use of
the package managers like npm or yarn
probably that's going to be the easiest
way to
add bootstrap to your project so i'm
going to show you how to do that so
let's create a new folder
uh npm let's open this with a
visual studio code
and let's quickly initialize the empty
npm project if you are not familiar with
npm i strongly encourage you to watch
some of the tutorials on how to use npm
because that
uh definitely gonna speed up your
development and with user frameworks
like react viewer and angular this is
kind of basics and our basic knowledge
is so uh it's very wise to to be
familiar with it so let's do npm init to
initialize a new project it's gonna ask
a couple of questions uh so the project
name let's call it bootstrap npm
and then
let's
just
um accept all the other default values
so we could
we could decide upon description entry
point and few other options which are
not required at this moment that's going
to create a
json file with all the settings and now
again let's create
index.html file and what we're going to
do now we're going to install the
dependency so i'm going to use npm
install
bootstrap which gonna
install all the dependencies under node
modules so as you can see we have down
node modules bootstrap and then we have
js css scss uh so for
those of you who want to um somehow
customize the boot drop probably this
would be
the way to work with so linking the css
we will be using this so let's uh now
link our
our uh dependencies here so again in the
head
let's do link and now we need to say
note
modules
bootstrap dist css and then bootstrap
css we can also use min
so minimize version of css and for the
body we're going to do exactly the same
so link
script
source
and then go to node modules bootstrap
this js this time
and bootstrap bundle js so this will
give us um again bootstrap plus the
dependencies
so let's do h1 hello
npm word
and let's open this
in
live server
so you can see already the font is there
and let's refresh network so we have
bootstrap css and bundle if you don't
want to use the bundle
but install the popper separately you
can obviously do it so just type npm
install
at
popper
js slash car minus minus save
and that will uh store it
in
under node modules
so now you will see uh and two folders
here so popper and bootstrap and
obviously you can link it now to
your project
okay so if you want to understand why
bootstrap becomes so famous
we have to start with the grid system
because this was the real game changer
back in the days um and before we
started learning because
before i'm going to show you uh how to
start using this in your projects in
your website um let me start perhaps
with some demo so you would better
understand it so um
i've got three examples here for you um
so to to give you uh some insight to
some feeling uh
what this grid and what this bootstrap
is about and why uh so many people on
the website use it uh let's have a look
at the following example so the um
the whole thing about the responsiveness
is that the content should adjust to
the screen of the size which you are
using so
you shouldn't prepare like two different
version of the page the same page for
different devices like mobile and
desktop version never one which will
simply behave like a water which
depending on what you pour it into it
will just you know use uh the whole
space available for it
so um the bootstrap uses uh the
bootstrap grid um uses columns to to to
achieve that goal and what you can see
here this is like the very basic example
so on a big screen when we have a plenty
of space we can easily uh fit this main
content here and the sidebar on the
right side right we have a full screen
we we have enough space we could even
make it a bigger larger but however
what's going to happen when we start
shrinking this uh you're going to see
that at certain point of time there is
not enough space
for you know
the entire content to fit in right it
becomes smaller and smaller and smaller
and if you have a lot of content over
here uh you might end up in situations
where it's just not enough right if you
if you go to the even smaller then
what's gonna happen thanks to bootstrap
is they're gonna stack one below
each other so um if you open uh web
developer console
and use this
mobile option you can choose one of the
predefined screen size so for example
we're going to check for iphone se and
then you will see how this actually
looks on
on the phone right so
you can also check some tablets i
believe here um yeah even on the nest
google nest hub so this is more of like
a tablet
view
so
this allows us to create very complex
structure like this one so imagine the
page you have some magazines whatsoever
with some sidebar header footer and so
on and thanks to bootstrap you can make
it to behave differently on a different
screen so i'm not sure if you notice
that is that
the some of them some of them they
simply disappeared right so our sidebar
is just gone so you can not only reorder
things depending on the screen size but
also
make them visible or invisible at the
certain screen sizes and finally
in this last example
hopefully explain will explain to you
the concept of these columns so what
bootstrap does how does it work is that
bootstrap
uses a rows and a columns and
within each row
you have
12 units to use to spare
so you can use them
as you like if you want to
spend the whole 12 unis the units of
width
um on the single row or on the single
column right so you want this main
content to be the full to have the full
width you are free to do so you can just
say that okay this column will take
12 units however you can obviously
divide it differently and use different
proportion so this example here how does
it work and what you see here this
double xl xl large medium sm these are
the screen size and we're gonna cover
them just in a second so this is what
you have to get familiar with so
bootstrap this defines a different
breakpoints so um
these are like this kind of you know
areas that we can define that the extra
small are the mobile phones small
uh between small and medium it's
something i don't know for example uh a
huge phones or the phones with the
larger screen like a couple of images
then the medium could be tablet and the
large it's going to be like desktop and
so on um
so
you can define the size of your column
for each and every screen size and
that's what you can see over here so
um this column has multiple properties
or actually you could say multiple width
assigned to it so
where we are currently
at now
is this size so it's double
large so this is for the screens which
are bigger than 1400 pixels and
obviously this is bigger so if you check
it here it shows that we are now at 16
hundreds
but
see what's going to happen if we start
shrinking below this break right so
i defined it i want this column to have
the unit of 1 and that's why we can fit
12 columns next to each other right we
have 1 2 3 four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve now what's going
to happen if i start shrinking the
screen and i'm gonna reach the the
breakpoint
all of the sudden the the size of the
column has changed and now the second
size has been applied so now each of the
column um
has size of two units so and now
obviously because as you remember as we
said this is 12 in total we can fit only
six columns next to each other and
that's what happened here right so one
two three four five six and another six
has just been wrapped let's continue and
let's uh
continue shrinking the screen and then
we once we reach the next one and the
next break point we are falling into
this
uh rule
or the this size which is three now
obviously if we have sines of three we
can just fit four because four times 3
gives us 12 and then if i continue
shrinking that
i'm gonna get into next one which is now
call md4 which means each column has
size of 4 so we can fit 3. if i continue
shrinking i will go into size sm6 which
means each of this has six and finally
at the smallest screen each of the
column will take the full available
width
for the screen so this is how it was
designed this is how this uh is so
amazing so uh yeah let's see uh let's
see let's learn how to use this
bootstrap grid now
so starting with breakpoints uh i
already told you how does it work so
bootstrap
comes with predefined breakpoints
so you have six of them and
this breakpoints are usually you know
they are adjusted to the most common
screen so
you can customize them if you want you
can change it uh however i think it
would be just wise to go with the
default value now
um
one we will be doing some coding in a
second uh so i want you to understand
that this grid consists of three
elements so what we always need if you
want to start using leads is grid it's a
row and these are columns one or
multiple so we do start with
the container so the container is going
to be the
the very first element which we which we
need which require if we want to work
start working with the
um
bootstrap grid and um so let's start
here um i have the
starting template here with just loaded
bootstrap css and js and let's uh
let's create a container here so you
could see how does it work
and some content and let's add i'm gonna
add class border
and let's open this one
okay so this is our container as you can
see it has some margins from the left
and from the right side so this is very
first thing you should know so if you
want to use the container to use the
full width so you would have your
columns starting from very left you
should use something called container
fluid
and what it does it will make use the
whole width all available here however
you can also do something which is
called a container combined with the
with the breakpoint so if you want to
mix it so depending on the screen
you want your
container
behave differently you can obviously
and easily do this with a bootstrap so
what you're gonna see here
is this is container however when we
start shrinking and we go below the
medium breakpoint then all of the sudden
the containers start behaving like a
container fluid right so you can simply
say that you want to
have the container fluid up till until
certain break point for example large
so if you can see it
from this table right so this uh it's
gonna have the 100 percent until
this resolution this screen size is met
so this is the very first thing it's
container now let's move to the grid
so the grid
consists of rows and equals rho there is
not much special about rows um
so let me just
use a bit of css here i'm gonna add some
styles which gonna help us to see the
columns so uh we're gonna see them uh
with your own eyes so i'm gonna do
something like this and let's start with
this very basic example so as i said
within our
container
we want to use a row
and inside our row i want to use columns
so you can use
something as simple as
call so i have two columns now and let's
just say call one
call two let's see how does it look like
so now you see actually maybe maybe you
don't see this yet
but if we go to inspector you will see
that this is our row and this container
so container is a little bit wider
and then we have a row here
um
usually you have you can have multiple
rows here
but what is really interesting are these
columns and i'm going to show you
example in a second with a few rows
but what's going on here now if we
use just the column um bootstrap will
basically
do the calculation do the math and it
will automatically
assign the proper wave for each column
which means that if i'm gonna
give you more columns
it will calculate the width and it's
going to use the equal values for each
right now if i want to have more
obviously i can just have more rows with
multiple columns
you can also have
more columns within a single row but
probably you are uh thinking or you
might be asking now okay what if i want
to use a specific size for a different
column and there is nothing
um
easier than that so
again
breakpoints
comes to the picture and we can use uh
we can use a columns
of a given size and i'm going to show
you two different options here so let's
get back to our code here let's get rid
of this one
and now let's do one thing we can do
strictly we
with saying just call
6 or let's do something else because 6
is equal so let's do call 4 and call
four so what's going to happen as you
can see we
said that this
should have width of four and this also
should have a width of four units and
now if we add another column here
let's call it auto bootstrap will
obviously automatically
fill up the this
remaining space and we can play with it
to achieve different results right
now um
this is however
not um
as flexible i mean
sometimes you want to use it because you
want to uh you want your columns to
always have the same size depending i
mean regardless of the of the screen
size so that's possible however more
often you will actually use
variable
with content which means that
except for providing this size you will
also want to provide the
break point what does it mean
let me show you that quickly so
if you do call
md and now 8
plus md
4
you're gonna see that we have this nice
8 and 4 distinction here however when we
start shrinking your screen
below medium what's going to happen is
that
our calls will take the full width
of a
full width
available within the container and now
as you can also see our container md
is changing to the 100 percent if i
stick it like this
it will keep the margins here available
uh however and those margins are gone
below the certain level because
basically bootstrap assumes that if you
are on mobile you you don't really want
to have these margins and if you want
then you should just do and add them
manually so um i hope you do understand
now how does it work obviously you can
first of all you can change this and to
something else um
so let's see let's do a large
so this is one thing so
now we're gonna get full width
already on the medium size and we're
gonna get this ratio on the bigger size
however the most important thing is that
you can also mix and match this like
call
md i know let's say six
and here six
which means that we have now three use
cases so a larger and larger than larger
medium
and smaller than medium right i hope you
are getting this now so you can that's
how you can create a very
very very uh complex examples and the
one uh let me show you quickly
one from the
from the demo which i was showing you so
this is the example with those columns
uh having
very
um
actually all the possible scenario right
so we have the size for each and every
screen size which allows us whoops not
this one this one which allows us to
really really create
um complex
scenario where you will be just you know
changing the size of
all of them
okay let's uh let's continue let's see
what else we have i mean there are
different options um
for mixing uh these columns together um
let's see and let's go through the most
common uh ones so what you're probably
gonna need quite often is an alignment
so let's have a look at this example
okay and now we need to do uh
border
let's get rid of
this two rows now for a second
and now let's
make it
a little bit bigger
so i'm just gonna do this manually
so now you can see that our row
has some height because of some content
which might be in there and if we want
to align them to the top we basically
say row align item start
and then if you want to do it in center
which is to the center if you want to be
aligned to the to the bottom we just say
stop align items end um so this is this
is the
this is the alignment
vertical alignment and obviously we also
might want to have the horizontal
alignment so uh coming back to this
let's have this container
a row and then let's have call
of size 2
and actually we want to have two of them
one and a two and now if we want to
justify them into the center we will do
something like this
and this will justify them to the center
right so regardless of
size they will be always aligned to the
center and there are different options
which you can obviously use here
so you have a round between
and depending on the use case you would
like to use
okay and
let's move to gutters now
so the cutters are responsible for the
for the distance between the columns
here
so let let's use this following
example hold on i'll just add
this one this div is
okay
okay so here we have gutters and
actually
let me reset this so these are gutters
and i'm gonna add some um
custom style here so you could see
one
more
thing
because it's not
easily visible
um so uh
within each
column i have created also the extra div
with the background so you could see
how actually the content
goes within and within the div itself
okay so before we start talking about
the gutter um
i need to explain one thing which is uh
used a lot within a bootstrap basically
when you've seen me using this
margin right and i said m y what does it
mean this means that i want to have
margin applied in the y
axis so uh it's for the top and for the
bottom if i would say mx i want talking
about the left and the right and the
same applies for the gutter right and by
the way we don't use gutter on container
we do it on row so let's start with
setting this to zero
okay so
this our
default uh
spacing and then
paddings and margins for the
for the columns uh under and the grid
bootstrap grid and now if we say g0
we gonna set them to uh we're gonna
basically reset them to zero now if i
let's see how it's gonna happen if i'm
gonna be changing this in the x-axis
what's gonna change so this is one
this is two this is three this is four
and this is five
so basically we are eliminating this um
budding here from the left and the right
let's say
one
and a five right so this uh how you
how you change uh this in the x axis and
let's do g y
and then a set from one
three
four
and five so this um you need to
understand what you need to understand
is that gx or the gutter uh in the x
position works actually um
uh here on this on the space between a
column and a row and in the y position
it's actually working in between the
columns here right so they are wrapped
up and then it's talking about the space
over here which you can
see on this example um obviously you
could try to do it with the margin and
padding duty which gonna cover in a
second however uh this is just the
easier way which was introduced in uh in
the
newest bootstrap to
to work on the more uh
complex scenario when you have multiple
columns and want to you want to work and
maintain the spacing in between them
okay so let's move to the first
component so i'm gonna cover um
the components from the most common one
uh so let's start with uh buttons
because we use them a lot you can also
see them being used here on the
bootstrap docs page
so uh
let me quickly open the workspace so i
created new folder for components so you
can easily reuse my my code if you want
if you want you can download it from the
github and so let me create a new file
for buttons so i'm going to call it
buttons html and i'm just going to copy
paste the
basic setup okay and open this in the
live server and now
let's uh let's grab one of the buttons
actually you know um the more you work
with the bootstrap obviously the more
you get familiar with it you will know
this syntax by heart so if you start
tapping button and then add some classes
like btn and then the color we're gonna
talk about the colors uh very soon but
now for your information bootstrap comes
with uh predefined colors and it calls
them like primary secondary sexist
danger and so on and you can adjust
these colors we're gonna cover that a
little bit later for now let's just use
primary and let's uh use some do
something like click me
and let's see how it looks like so you
can see that you have this button start
right so obviously
if you would go with the
just simple button
it looks like this
and simply by adding these classes btn
and then color you are getting this
slice over here and you can see more of
it over here so let's just add few more
so we can see them
right so these are different predefined
buttons now bootstrap allows you to
easily
a
adjust uh both color
as well as size and few other properties
uh so for example here you can see that
bootstrap comes with the so called
outline buttons right which which which
have right here just let's just do it
like here so i'm gonna add the new
uh i'm gonna add the new
row here
so this container let me add another one
so we could see them
next to each other or one below the
other so this is the primary and this
primary outline secondary and so on and
so on um here you see the light or
actually you can't see it so it's used
uh in the certain uh circumstances um
but other than than than just the
outline uh we can also easily adjust the
size of our button so if we want to do
the container
by the way i'm going to add some
classes here my5 we're going to learn
about it
as well
soon but this will give us some space
and cure
um
so if you want to do something larger
like uh like the larger or smaller
button we can simply use this btn large
so let me just use this one here and the
same for small so if we do btn sm
we're gonna get small
and let's add
just
compare
all together let me just remove it so
just call it irregular button so you
will see
the difference right so this is large
this is the regular and this is the
small button so you can do it
you can also disable any button
simply by adding the disabled uh
property and then as you can see that's
also gonna be styled right so it's gonna
looks like now
this there are a couple more so you can
you have the block button so if you want
to have the full width um you can use
this block buttons
and actually you know the button is
commonly very commonly used within the
bootstrap because uh for example
you can use it to to toggle state so as
you can see here you have the active um
so if i click on it it becomes active so
you can see the color is changing and
then if i click again it
it is getting deactivated
and
lots more because you also gonna see um
for example buttons being used as a
dropdowns for example uh like here um so
it's really it's really wise to get
familiar with with it um
then there are there are methods uh
related to two buttons it's a little bit
more advanced so uh we're gonna leave it
for for the later
but one important thing regarding your
buttons it's also that you can um like
everything actually in bootstrap you can
easily
adjust it using or adjusting the
variables which comes
with the sas of the bootstrap satisfies
so
if you want to change the generic look
of the
of buttons or you want to create new
ones you can also do it with the use of
a css
next very commonly used components are
cards so you're going to see them almost
everywhere so uh let's see how they look
um
in
the real world so here is the basic
example uh by the way if you if you
check the docs you can see that it's
like it's a really huge tremendous uh
amount of uh examples which you can use
with both swap so we're gonna cover the
most important ones so let's start with
the with the examples uh the basic
example shows us the uh one of the very
often scene cards so the card with the
image title
um and some kind of folder it's not
exactly the footer but yeah let's uh
let's call it this way i'm gonna show
you the real footer in a second so let's
copy this one
um because this is going to show us the
issue with what you're going to face if
you start using this for the very first
time
let's add some image here so i'm going
to use
image pixel
for that so this is very interesting
service which allows you easily to use
some images uh so you could
have the real image and you can easily
change the size so here we have 200 by
300 so uh let's
see
how it looks in
our case so this is the card actually we
didn't want like this we wanted to have
let's say 300 by 200 so something more
like this one and
add some spacing here um
as you can see every time we refresh we
are getting some random patch so it's
it's pretty cool to see this uh
used it's kind of testing right because
you can already see with a different
option um now talking about it let's um
jump into the sizing so uh
because
here our
card has a certain sign as you can see
this is because we added some star over
here if we remove it
um you're gonna notice that if you want
to start that what we're gonna do in a
second if you start typing this uh just
by hand right so if you just create this
and at this
class card which is actually making a
card
looks like a card giving some borders um
to it and you're gonna notice that this
gonna happen so it's gonna take the full
wave
available um so how we can how we can um
work of them let's go to sizing so there
are a few options uh there so first is
obviously already known to you so if you
use row and then you're gonna add let's
say call 2 in it and you're going to
wrap up
your card
into it so you will be able to decide
upon the size by using simply grid so
depending on the column size you're
gonna get smaller or bigger cards um
then the
next option here will be to use these
utilities so let me
get rid of
this one or let's go
with the another row here
and let's get this card again from here
so let me copy this card entirely and
paste it here and now it will take the
whole whole wave available and now we
can use the utility which we're going to
cover
but you can already learn this one which
is
w75 which stands for with 75 a percent
and you can see this example here i'm
not sure you can clearly see this this
is uh this stands for 75 percent which
is over here this one stands for 50
which stands over here so let's uh give
it a try let's say 50 we want to have
our card to fulfill the 50
of the space uh here
um so this is the the the second option
and the third one you actually have seen
because we've been using this ram before
so let's just add it
for the sake of
consistency so you would have all your
cards um in all possible scenarios
so let's add just styles
and now we have three uh i'm done um
okay now let's get back to the to the
basics so uh let's
go with the new
row over here
and let's do call 3 for the sizing
let's see how the very basic basic card
looks like so let's do adjust the card
and let's do some lower m5
let's
give it here okay and let's add some
actually you know what let me give it
to the top right and that's an
my5 and let's get this one to the top so
we could easily
see this one
here
okay so it's here on top so this how the
uh how the how the card looks like so it
doesn't look good yet
but what we
are gonna get if we gonna add
card
body that's gonna look
much better
than that than what we've got before
and this is already looking giving us
some nice look it has some paddings it
has some margins so this is something
which sometimes some people call panels
right so you could have those patterns
over
here now what we can do uh we can add
certain elements and this is very cool
because
you can compose your cards from these
sub elements as you wish right so um if
you want to if you want to add for
example the image to to our card you can
easily do that by adding this still
within our cart but above body we can
add image with the class card
image top
and reuse our
image here
and this will automatically um
link this image to our cart
um
i'm gonna skip the list groups for a
second as you can see these these are
kind of few panels connected to each
other
and let's move to the header and the
footer section because that's what is
interesting um so uh
let's let me
get
the
another
card over here
and instead of the image let's use
a card
um header
so this is what we're going to add here
so let's get rid of this image here and
let's add
um
card header instead
so this is our current header
and it's going to add as nicely looking
cutter now since we have a header
obviously
we can add some footer as well so let's
use example of this one actually let me
just copy paste this one
so
let's add it here here we have a text
muted and let's see how it looks without
that
first
so here we have footer and if we add
this text muted it just
slightly mute this to make it less
visible as this is the uh folder
obviously and this is uh we don't want
to see this uh like now screaming to our
uh users right so this is how you work
with that and i think you can have
really nice um
results using that let's have a look at
pre-defined examples because they're
going to give you also some idea of what
you can achieve with that here are
examples with cards within the
navigation we're going to cover that in
the navigation pod
so here you have also the image examples
and how to work with them
but let's
slightly uh
move further to this example so here we
have this horizontal card which looks
really really nice so let me add another
call over here
so let's have call
tree
let's paste this example and let's just
grab the image again
however oh we don't have image here we
have image here
so um
[Music]
what
we're gonna do here we're gonna replace
this
image or actually these three dots with
image now change the ratio so i'll have
200 by 300 now
let's see how it looks
now i think it's too small so uh that's
because probably here
we would like to have it slightly bigger
yeah now it looks better right so now we
have three plus three plus six it's sum
to 12. it's good and here we have this
horizontal card so
i think it really looks nice
um but other than that um
you also have
something which is called card groups so
very often you will see and we're also
going to build it at the very end of
this tutorial we're going to build a
simple page
um so you probably will see something
like this when you have a page and then
you have your blog and let's say you
want to list like last three articles on
the page you would see something like
this so what you could do you could
create like three columns um with the
size of four so four plus four or plus
four or you could use card groups which
would also looks nice so uh again um
it's it's pretty much the same as the
normal card right you have a cards here
the only thing you have to remember is
to add this class card group added up so
let's have a look at this one now so we
have a row here and let's add another
row
with some margins
in between and now
let's
replace this one
with the
image
so i want to have this this
this and that
and i want to have
this image
here
and this how it looks like i think it
really looks it looks really really nice
so this is this uh this
card groups how they looks like and and
as you can see there are many many more
here's the example of uh of the cards
next to each other uh so obviously we're
not gonna cover all of that because
there's uh there's there's a lot
examples but let's get back to a few
more examples because they're also
interesting um you will probably see
them in for example like admin
dashboards so you can have this this
card uh having different styles so you
can reuse the same colors which you've
seen
when it comes to buttons so uh simply by
adding this classes like background
primary
to our cart right so here we specified
this is just a simple card let's have a
look at this example
um
so let me add let's see what we have
space here let's one two three let's
edit here before
below the
card group so let's have another row and
i have call
3
and let's have this card here and let's
get rid of this for a second
so this is like
normal basic card no right but if we
start playing with the colors so i'm
gonna
revert this text white
and the background primary what we're
gonna see is that it will change color
to something like that
so uh let's duplicate this one so we
have called three one
two three so now we should have four
cards one two three four and let's
change them colors of it so
yeah i like this this dark one so let's
go here and choose background dark and
text white for the second one
so i believe this is the first
so this is the second one
um by the way this mb stands for margin
bottom so it's adding some merging uh
margin on the bottom here uh don't worry
we're gonna cover margins uh in a few
seconds you can see you know black one
and yeah let's just
do two more so let's say info with the
text dark for the next one
and
for the last one let's say we want to
have text white and danger so this is
the last card here
and
voila these are our cards and now again
another row
for
last examples let me just copy them
to make it faster so let's just do one
two
three and four
so this row
let's paste it
and these are examples of
the outline cards
by the way it doesn't work here let me
see why
now it actually does it just looks this
way right
header
hold on
no something doesn't work here but
probably
because
they have to be placed within a call not
row so here we're gonna have them um
yeah so these are
these are
border
with cards or cards with border
and different examples of this so as you
can see there are plenty of variation
over here which you can use obviously
you can also easily align them
and play with it
and like everything in bootstrap you can
also work with
sas variables to change for example the
distances between cards or
or background color or
anything like that um so yeah i mean i
really like this component and i've been
using this a lot
in my projects so i strongly encourage
you also to have a look because it's
it's very very useful component
okay now we'll jump to a different
category which is uh content and exactly
typography uh in bootstrap so let me
quickly create new
uh folder to organize it slightly so now
we'll move to content
and i'm just gonna grab the
index so our template from
components and let's open this in
visual studio code okay
so um bootstrap comes
with um predefined styles for the for
the
um
different
types of typography so starting with
headings
uh let me just copy paste this one okay
we also need to create new file here
typography so this is one of the
so-called utilities and bootstrap have
more of them
now i can
paste it here
all right i need to
get this one and then i'm ready to
put it within our container
um so let's have a row here
and let's save it open
and let's see what is interesting uh
about the um
about the heading and actually the whole
typography is that unlike almost
everything in bootstrap uh it is um
responsive right so uh let's check this
element and let's see the computer's
size um
computed styles so let's have a look at
the font size which is currently 31.95
pixels however if i'm gonna start
adjusting the screen size you can see
that this value is actually
changing
um so now it's 40 pixels and then if we
shrink it it's going to become smaller
and to
what is it now 24
pixel so this is uh this is also very
very useful while working with uh with
bootstrap
because obviously uh it looks just
better it adjusts to the screen aside
now
what bootstrap offers you as well is um
the class which will make um the
actually any element to look like the
heading so there are situations
there are situations where we don't
really want to
have
use h1 h2 for let's say
different reasons like seo um so let's
say these are paragraphs
looking like
headings and if we just apply these
classes like h1 h2 h3 we're gonna get
exactly the same look right so we have
it here actually we can do it even
better so let's do it like this
so we could see the difference
um so these are headings
let's call them real headings
and let's do
call
md
six
two times
and let's move this one inside first
column and this one into the other one
so now we should see them
side by side
let me close this one
and slightly
make it bigger so now you can see that
they look
exactly the same
so if you want for some reason to
your
whatever paragraph looked like a heading
you can do it with use of this
bootstrap also comes with um
this display heading so they are
slightly bigger so if you really want to
something to you know stand out um to be
more visible you can do it with uh with
this displays so let me just
show you that so you use classes like
display one display do and this will
give you that result
um
what else
obviously it comes with a lot of
inline text elements uh inline tags so
we can highlight
we can actually uh
cross out texts you can ask why
um why they are um
like duplicated right so you have two
for for this one right so
and here you have this this text is
meant to be treated as deleted and this
line of text is meant to be treated as a
long longer accurate
um
so
the difference is actually semantics
right so um
for example in case of this
s here it represents elements that are
no longer relevant or no longer uh
accurate while this one was deleted so
so this is like a
very very subtle difference um but this
is what is it all about
so uh yeah that might be new to you but
they are different uh since html5 that
this the smarting really does matter so
um you should carefully use it but other
than that as you can see you have uh
support for like you know
making the bold or
uh you know highlighted text with the
use of it so let me just add it over um
to our example so again we could
um
yeah let's have a new row here
and let's have um
just put it like this
right so we're gonna have all the
examples
in one place
as always there are more um many more
examples uh like abbreviation like blog
quotes um so maybe maybe let's have a
closer look at the blog clause as they
might be useful for you
so
row
so uh whenever we want to use block
quote
um let's do some paragraph and lorem
here
so that's how the
uh normal looks like so doesn't really
look different however
if we add this class
to it
now
it looks
uh differently so this is the this is
the example um over here so this is the
basic block code however
you can also
use um
the more extended version with a footer
right like here so we can add
this specific caption
with the class block code footer which
will make it uh
looks differently um so let's do this
side by side call
md6
actually i want to have
two or maybe
let's say even
four
i'm gonna change the size i'm gonna have
three of them so the second one is with
the footer and this one will be the
basic one
and
then
the one which shows you how you can
actually align text with the use of the
text alignment so we're gonna check that
here you can already see that by using
text center or as a class text center on
our
element we can um we can change the
alignment of the text so let's use the
the last example here um right
so let's just actually do it this way
just to show you how to do it by
yourself so i'm just gonna add to this
feature class
text
and and the reason uh
the reason it's um it's end now it's
because uh and not right and left it's
because uh since bootstrap 5 there isn't
support for rtl so from you know in in
many countries we do read from from left
to right so in your case it will be from
left to right i believe um if you're
watching me on the camera but obviously
this is not the case for all the
countries so in the in the arabic
countries uh it's the other way around
so while they
added the support for the rtl they also
had to change the naming because
obviously the left uh doesn't
necessarily always means that so if you
use rtl then then it could be confusing
so now it starts and end and you're
gonna see more on that when we go to the
spacing utilities now let's just have a
look how it looks like so here are our
block quotes you can see them here and
this one is aligned to the right side um
finally
um
bootstrap offers you uh
an option for
the
for the list
so if for some reason you don't want
your list
to have any kind of you know dots or
points um so uh
you can use this list unstyled here
so uh yeah let's do it quickly so we're
gonna have ul
with class
list
unstyled
okay and inside that i want to have
li
um l i
um
with
the content
the line
number
and we want to have like five of them
oh no we want to have
like
five of those obviously
um so now we're gonna have this line
over here and then again i'm gonna
quickly do
new
on order list
and
with
some numbers here
a line
multiple by
say three by the way if you're wondering
what i'm doing i'm just using an ammet
which allows me
to
create
easily
the different amount of
um
elements simply by uh using this uh the
shortcut so if you don't know that i
strongly encourage you to check the
tutorial on the embed because it's gonna
make your life much more easier uh why i
did it uh like this i wanted to show you
that this class applies only to the in
to the to the immediate choice of those
um
of any element you use it on so this
sub lines they already have style again
um and then finally if you want to use
uh inline so this is the case usually
when you do some kind of navigation
right so you want to have like a nav bar
right what they have over here for
example this is the this that could be
used or created with the use of of the
list inline list so all the elements
will be basically printed next to each
other and now not one below the other so
again call
md6
multiplied by two times
and i'm gonna get this one from the
documentation and i'm gonna grab
that one from here
and this will show us this next to each
other i'm gonna add some spacing later
on for you
so when you when you refer to this file
later on uh you'll clearly see so i'm
gonna add something like
heading one um at least
styles and
uh maybe i'll use cutters or
um
why
all right so you'll have
this separated so you can easily
refer to it and realize what we are
actually talking about or maybe it's
even better if i do it here
[Music]
yeah i to give some space in between
okay let's move
move on
um
so uh what is um
also important to mention here is that
as i mentioned you um
at the beginning of this section um the
phones are responsive so uh this is cool
but
bootstrap went even further a step
further and they came with this
responsive
font sizing so rfs
project so this is a separate project um
and this you can find it on a github
um actually this is really cool because
that allows you to change um not only
the font size and that's how then they
came up with the name right so
originally they wanted to to adjust the
font size depending on the screen size
uh however now they mo they went uh
even further because initially it was
default they developed to resize the
phones um but nowadays um rfs is capable
of scaling actually you know basically
every value of any css property with
unions like you know margin paddings
border radius and so on and so on um so
let me just show you a quick demo over
here so if you if you if you watch
carefully you're gonna see that when the
screen resizes over here also the
different um
and different things are changing here
so not only did the font size but also
the paddings and margins and this all
this this make it uh you know to look um
much better for example on the very big
screens uh like you know 4k now
we're not gonna go into this one because
it's a separate project uh
but uh i think it's it's worth to to
just just just uh
be aware of the fact because you might
need to
um at a certain point of time when it
comes and you'll have to work on the
fonts or some paddings to to make them
look good
on on for example very very very huge
screen so that's
where this rfs might be very useful
okay so let's move to the images now um
bootstrap allows you to easily make
images responsive so uh let's have a
look at
the following example so um i'm going to
create
a div
with a border so you could see
how it looks like so let's have
let's have a div
i'm going to give it some custom styles
so for the sake of
this tutorial and so with
let's say 40 percent
and also i want to have a border
um five pixel red solid so we could see
it
okay now obviously we need some
content into it so we could see it
so let's add image
and let's
add
some logo here now you can clearly see
that this is our this is our div
uh so if we check this in inspector now
it's it's become even smaller now
because inspector popups here so now the
40
is even smaller so uh yeah this is this
is the
this is the diff right this this part
the bluish one and
this this orange is not um okay so uh
as you can see sometimes the the image
the content uh just simply go out of our
borders and what you can do how you can
quickly fix it is by simply adding a
class to our image called image fluid
and this will make our image responsive
so uh yeah i mean that's that's that's
really basic but also very very very
important
um
future feature uh then if we go to if we
go further um let me do
h1
my five
and let's go to thumbnail
and let's
uh
let's have this image
however we're gonna change this to image
thumbnail
so
um that will give our image something
which let me enlarge it here so it's
gonna give
this style this border rounded border
around it
um let's also do
let's make it a little bit smaller so
with the use of with 25 i just make it
smaller now the finally the the last
option you can see here um
is how to align how to actually align
images with use of bootstrap so let's do
that now
let me close copy this one and then
let's have
alignment
um so
basically we will be using the float um
utility which we're gonna discuss uh in
a second so um yeah let's just do let's
just copy this image again
so this was the one
and let's change
this one to
uh to the float
let's say
and
so this will move oh yeah let's make it
smaller
so this will move our image to the end
and now obviously uh if we are working
with the floating we need to remember to
use the clear fix so clear
fix
um so because otherwise um maybe let me
show you that um let's have some
paragraph here here
otherwise other elements will be
floating around it so maybe i will even
use
lorem 50
so you could see
what i'm talking about oh it's too not
enough okay fine let's use 100
so this is floating our image um so
now
if we add
the
clear fix over here
basically that's gonna fix that state
now okay uh let me get rid of this
paragraph we don't need it anymore
because i want to show you also how you
can actually
center the image with
use
of bootstrap classes so let's get this
image again
and we can simply do
that
by uh adding by using the flexbox so d
block
um
mx auto
and through 25
and this will center our image um like
this one and one more thing actually i
didn't mention is that we can easily for
example make our image
or give our image
uh
rounded corners like here
simply by by adding this
rounded class to it
and the last but not the least if you
are working with picture
um
it's also supported by bootstrap so here
you have the syntax for working with the
pictures and making uh them also a
responsive um like we did with the
previous examples
okay so now let's move to the youtube
list because this is also one of the
most important part of the bootstrap and
especially
taking into account that recently
thailand
become more and more famous and this is
the so-called u2d first framework so i
would like to also show you that a lot
of these utilities options are available
uh within bootstrap as well so we're
gonna go through the utilities
but i want to start as always from the
most uh i believe the most common most
important one which is spacing however
we're gonna
go through all of them so um what i did
i prepared this um sample div with some
content here
which is actually styled using styles
and i'm gonna recreate this for you just
using the bootstrap classes so we will
achieve exactly the same effect with uh
with the use of the bootstrap utilities
so let me do now let me do it
like this i'm gonna grab
this div
and i'm gonna
add it
below
and let me get rid of all styles over
here
so we don't need this this
that and
ignore this okay so we have just simple
this um here
and
let me also add
some
margin here actually we can already
start with um discussing the spacing you
so
you've already seen me using some of
them um in the previous parts so uh
let's quickly go through the tr theory
um so
it's fairly simple because you stay in
order to use this utility you simply add
the proper class like
mt
five for example which will stands for
margin top
five and this will give us some a little
bit space over here
now um
as you can see uh already m stands for
margin p stands for padding and there
are different um way you can combine it
so uh like we did so usually you start
with property and then side so you do
like margin and then side which is top
and then the value so the size
is from zero to five it's also accept
auto which we're going to use in a
second
basically
bootstrap defined a spacer so like a
basic value and different different
numbers different values here from 0 to
5 are actually multiplying this by
different values like here it's 25 of
the basic spacer so at this one will
will make it to 25
and then it will the two will multiply
um
all by half so it's actually it's gonna
it's gonna use half of the value three
is the default spacer and then four and
five is selected again a bigger um
amount like one and a half times more
and then three times more than the basic
value um so well yeah let's let's see
let's see how does it work in a practice
and also by the way this is um something
which i also mentioned to you already so
bootstrap in the version 5 change uh the
naming convention so before we had top
bottom left right so but now it's start
and the end because of
because of rtl right so right to left or
left to right and depending on which one
you use
before we go to the spacings let's um
let's let's add some border here because
that will just make it um
a little bit easier to see what we want
to achieve so what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna add the border
to this uh which will give us this
border uh it's it's very light actually
i lost the
top
uh margin okay that's cool and now uh to
make it a little bit thicker i'm gonna
add border
one to define the size
and also i'm gonna do border dark
okay so this is gonna
make it slightly bigger so this what you
can see here
you can again obviously defined whether
you're going to have the entire border
or
just the one of the borders or one of
the corners so um yeah you can obviously
define a color of of the border like
we've been doing
before so with the colors um you
probably already noticed that we've been
using this primary secondary success
denture and so on let's have a look how
the colors utilities looks and work like
so we have these basic colors defined
and we can use them for
both
coloring our content like a text or um
also to do the backgrounds so this is
here background which uses exactly the
same you know colors it just uses
different classes so background primary
background secondary and so on and so on
um there are different color variations
over here right you can even specify the
gradients um
you can you can specify the opacity and
so this is all
possible with an uh bootstrap
now talking about the colors as
everything is almost everything within a
bootstrap it's it's uh customizable so
uh there are there are variables which
you can adjust if you want to change the
skin color um but you know i
i hope you get the point that if you are
using everywhere like you know the
primary secondary and so on and so on so
once you define decide to change the
color scheme uh to change the layout of
your page in the future you just change
the single value and it's gonna update
everywhere in the in the page okay so uh
we've got this one uh what we are
missing to have the same um kind of
result over here we need to also shrink
it a little bit
so
let's do it
with the um size
so if you go to the sizing utility
you're going to see something which i
already used before so i want to add
w
50 we're gonna set this width to the 50
right and we need to center it we need
to center it um
so um for for the centering this um we
also did it in the previous but let's
just go to the
uh position
so uh actually position something
different positions uh is where you can
define
um
your um your position value like static
relative absolute what we are actually
looking for um is within the spacing so
where we just started just down below
its horizontal centering um so we're
going to use mx auto which i'm gonna set
our margins to um to auto uh from on
both sides or
so mx i think i didn't mention that so i
think it's a good
time to say about it because um maybe
you've seen it already uh however
except for the specific directions like
a top bottom start and the end you also
have the axises right so the x will work
on the x axis and the y will work on the
y-axis so the horizontal and the
vertical one okay so now once we have
work on the on the alignment and the
border let's uh see how the these
paddings look um in work um so uh let's
do uh let's do
something like this let's say we're
gonna have padding left
or actually start
five
this is gonna add as this padding from
the left side which you can see over
here obviously we could do it from the
right side so then we need to switch to
end pointing end we can do the top
we can have different values so we could
have p uh t5 and p start on the tree
let's say so you see that the values are
a difference um then again we can do px5
which is gonna give us paddings for both
from both directions left and the right
um or we can just say if we don't
specify the direction itself it's going
to apply this to all the directions on
top right
bottom and the left as well now the same
applies to the margin so let's work on
that using
this paragraph so i'm going to add class
here so then again you can see that if i
do margin top five this i've been using
this uh a bit uh it's gonna add me the
margin here if i want to do margin
y so in both directions it should change
this um
just space over here let's let's see how
it works without so this class is
incorrect now so we don't have any
margins here if i go to five it will add
both from the top and the bottom
um so yeah i will
leave it to five so it's going to be
margin from each and every direction and
finally this div what we what we have
here we have a width
50. so you already know that right so
class
it's w
50 for 50 and we need to we need to
align it so let's do mx auto
to set it in the center
what else we have here oh we have a text
alignment we didn't talk about it
but we i think i've used it already in
the previous example but let's just see
how it works so
uh for this we just need to do text
center and this will do
the same here so this
this text alignment was there before in
the
way we were talking about the typography
um so this is this is something you
already seen now what else we have here
we have background um so if i go with
background
light i believe i'm gonna get a little
bit
a bit grayish over here it's slightly
gray i'm not sure if you can see it so
let's do background dark then which
should give us the pretty much the same
dark gray color and finally
text white
for the white color so this is again
what you can find here
in the colors right so um you can either
use this primary secondary uh but there
are also um colors which are uh
predefined like you have the best blue
indigo purple and so on and so on um
you can also use the grayscale right so
you have a gray 100 degree 300 and so on
so you can achieve this as well with
simple use of classes what else we have
here so we talk about backgrounds we
talk about the borders we talk about the
colors uh display obviously you can you
can define whether you want to how you
want to display
a given element so you don't need to
change the display property you can just
add simply add the for example d
um
none
so this will this will make our
paragraph totally disappear let me
revert the change
and now the paragraph is back what is
also interesting is that you can also
use the breakpoints right we already
learned about the breakpoints where we
were talking about the grid so we can
actually apply um apply this on these
certain
breakpoints on the certain screen size
so for example if you want to see
let's say we want to be something
visible only on the let's say medium
size
let's do let's add this here
so now
our our div is visible
however oh
oh obviously this is
uh
i didn't remove
the dots
so now it got disappeared and when we
increase
the size of the screen
we should see
that it will pop up
once we
reach
oh where are you
oh now it is so because we had d none so
basically we don't display this um on
starting from smallest screen then we
have the md block so if you are on the
medium size break point between medium
and large now we can see it and then if
we go to large again it's going to be
disappearing right so if you want to do
this on the specific uh screen size that
that's how you can do it so you can
specify very complex rules or if we just
get rid of this the lg none then it will
be just simply um invisible on the small
screen until we got the medium size and
then after we start making bigger bigger
it will be visible right so this is very
very useful to for example you know hide
something on the mobile or show
something on only on mobile um so uh
yeah let's get familiar with this one
because it's gonna be very useful now
flex um obviously uh
flags is um
very um
important in the web development so
again instead of using the reflex
styles uh or css properties you can
simply add the classes which gonna be
using and utilizing the flex so uh we're
gonna do
another example uh on that let's grab
something from here
um so uh yeah i mean
as you already know i mean if you are
not familiar with flex then obviously uh
please uh do uh check the tutorial on
flex fast because otherwise it's gonna
be a little bit confusing but other than
that if you are actually familiar with
flags already then you can
use just
you can you can easily see in the
documentation um how to apply this flex
properties with just simple use of the
um classes right so the classes
utilities which will um do this for us
and we don't need to type the css um
ourselves so basically long story short
just to enable flags you should do the d
flex which is going to make
we're going to apply flex to this to
this container
and then we can we can start working on
a different
example here
so uh yeah let's just grab one of those
from here
and let's
let's check this out let's add
border
so we could see it
and
by the dark
margin top five so something you already
know and now let's just check how it
looks in
in console
so you'll clearly
see
that this the
flags
class
is setting this display to flex
and then and the flex row is setting
this to to row and then uh
obviously we can we can we can we can we
can uh
just play with it we can have like flags
row reverse right so uh
this will reverse
the
um the order right so now it's one two
three here although it's like one two
three here in the code uh we're going to
go to columns right so if you want to
change
to columns instead of rows you can also
do it just simply
changing this class so we have columns
now and so on and so on that which gives
you a lot of you know option just to
justify content easily talking about
justification bootstrap also uh helps
you to
vertically align so everyone who was
trying to vertically align
uh or center or something you know that
it in the past it used to be a real pain
um
for the
developers to do it with the css now
you can simply just use the align middle
and that will
just
set it to a middle so yeah also very
very useful um utility float we've been
using already with images right so
simply set float start fold and keep in
mind not using left right just start at
the end
um what else the interaction right when
you click on it it's gonna
select the entire text rank this doesn't
have the behavior and this can't be
selected so
a lot of you do this which just makes
your life easier you can change the
opacity with the simple class and the
value over here
um
change the overflow
uh so then again if you want to have a
scroll or not if you want your content
to overflow simply say overflow visible
just add the class and your content will
become
automatically visible hidden if you want
to cut it out like we could do with our
image example right if we was too big we
could just set it to overflow hidden and
then our image won't go out of the um
out of the div
out of the power and div obviously um
yeah
if we didn't use the image fluid
for to make it responsive then it would
be obviously invisible uh fully right so
the part of the image will be just gone
position we talked already right so you
can arrange you can set it to static
relative and then if you go
decide to
um to
to go with the absolute or relative you
can also specify like position absolute
top 50 start 50 and this will set it to
correspondingly
um shadows uh we haven't used it i
believe so let's just
quickly have a look so let's do shadow
large
so we could see the result easily and
let's add it to our div
here
so this is gonna give nice
shadow around the element over here
um
and then finally we talked uh about
sizing like we set with width and and
height
and
spacings margin padding's text um so uh
yeah this is this is about for example
wrapping an overflow for the text right
here
uh vertical line and visibility which uh
you can all which can be also
um
adjusted with the use of visible or
invisible class
okay so now let's get back to content
and specifically to the table so
i've got you two tables here um and
we're going to make one of
one of this table responsive table
responsive and also going to show you
what else we can do with the bootstrap
classes um how we can easily change and
and adjust it
so uh first let's let's make it uh let's
make this uh responsive so uh what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna add um this
table
responsive
md so i'm specifying not only do i want
this table to be responsive but i'm also
specifying the break point
from which onwards i want this be
responsive so as you can see
the
upper table is just getting shrinking
shrinking shrinking
and the bottom one got the scroll which
allows us to easily browse it for
example on the mobile right so
this how you can um
this is how you can you can do it and
there is a much
more uh which you can actually do with
the um you know with the uh
tables using uh using bootstrap so let's
have a look at just few examples because
again obviously as you can see there are
a lot options here like you know you can
play with uh table footer header styling
them easily so i just want to show you
uh a few um
examples which i used most often here we
got the table responsive
so
yeah so it can be always responsive or
it can be on the specific breakpoint
so
what else we can do with
with
with the table
we can easily um and this is something
which bootstrap was working on um
very hard uh when it migrated from
bootstrap 4 to bootstrap 5. uh i mean
a dark team so if we do table
dark
it's gonna change our table to the dark
mode which is very handy because you
know with just single switch you know
that a lot of pages do have now right
this um this night mode
which programmers do love so much at
least i do
what else if you want to
make it bordered simply just type table
bordered
bordered and this will add as those
borders and as you've seen the decks you
can also specify which borders you want
which words you don't want to um let's
add table hover and let's see what's
going to happen so now we can when we
hover over the
given row it's going to highlight so
it's also very very useful when it comes
to the
big tables with a lot
amount of data
you can also to make it easier for your
users to
to read the data you can add table
stripped which will basically make every
odd cell having different color and you
can also change colors right like
everything with bootstrap i can do table
primary for example we're going to
change the color or info
and you have a nice overview of all this
uh variants here right so you have all
the colors and options here um yeah so
these are the most important
utilities which you can use with your
tables as you can see it's very very
easy and you can
very quickly
change and adjust your existing table
because what you have to do this is just
a very plain table html table what you
have to do is just to add a proper class
to it and it's going to look amazing
thanks to bootstrap
okay so now i would like to talk about
the two other components which are very
useful to make your site more dynamic so
if you're creating some platform or you
know some dashboard admins uh very often
you want to show some kind of
notification so there are two
interesting components which bootstrap
offers you to use the first one is
called others so um this is how it looks
like uh you might be you know you're
familiar with those kind of arts
whenever you are working with some
platforms you click on something and
then usually in the top you can see this
kind of alert this is very um
easy like most of the components within
a bootstrap but what is most important
for except for the fact that uh this is
a is simply simple to use simply to
create that you can add icons to it um
is if you change color is that they're
dismissible so you know whenever you
show it you can also get rid of it by
just clicking this x icon
so let's tell you how to how to build it
and
yeah as you can see this is this is very
simple because you just need to use a
proper classes so the first use alert
and then
a color so
this is the primary one so we just use
an alert and alert primary um and if you
want to make a dynamic you should also
keep in mind to to use the role and now
bootstrap
utilizes the svg icons so if you want
you can easily add
your icons to
the alert so simply add svg
and i'm going to show you more icons
soon
and finally if you use a bootstrap
plugin
and the alert plugin all
or
the
compiled bootstrap javascript version
which we are using here then um simply
by adding this data attribute or
actually adding this button here right
so this is this is button
and the one you can see over here this
is just a button which looks like this
um and by giving them
this class button close and this data bs
dismiss
attribute it will work and it will
automatically um do their job so it
would just remove it so just keep in
mind that uh when you dismiss uh it's
actually being completely removed from
the page structure
now let's move to the next one which is
toast and the toast are
a little bit smaller and elements on the
page which are also dismissible and they
can be also shown
on request so um let's let's uh let's
check this one um so i'm going to copy
in this
example here i'm going to create another
row for it actually
we don't need row specifically because
by default it's not visible and we need
to use the
we need to use the javascript as to
create a button which will basically
which will basically
make it live so
as you can see it's popping up here in
the bottom right corner so actually
let's use this example
which we have here because what is
important here is uh this piece of
javascript and we're gonna go through it
um so uh yeah let's have a button and
the um
toast
so uh
basically the the structure is pretty
simple uh if you use this code uh pro
probably doesn't make sense to
uh you know um type it all by yourself
simply copy the example and then adjust
whatever you need so uh here you can
have an image right this is the image
they used uh you've got the header
bootstrap and then some some extra
information
button close which you already know from
alerts and then the body of your message
you can customize it you can add images
you can get add content it's up to you
and then we need this uh this piece of
javascript over here so let's add script
tag here
and let's paste it let's see if this
works
so here we've got our
toast on the left side this time so as
you can
imagine you can easily
adjust
either content or behavior so whether
you want to
whether you want to
show this
this this
toast
on the left on the right side you can
you can easily customize it if you want
a few of them right so you want to stack
them here we have just single
single uh notification single toast over
here however maybe you want to show two
or three or four or five or more uh then
they will they can also stack one below
each other so um you can
you can you can just just do that
uh
don't forget to add some spicing uh to
it
now maybe let's have a look at this uh
piece of
piece of javascript over here because
what it does uh first it
create a link to the
into the button right so to the to the
button you can see over here
so we assign it to the toast trigger and
then
we are getting this toast live example
which is
here
live toast right so you you catch your
toast by
my
id
and then you
whenever this is clicked
you simply use the show option
there should be
the other example here
and
there's the usage right
so if you have multiple tools you can
also use um
you can initialize them this way so um
simply just uh
search for all the elements with the
class toast and then you'll end up with
the list of uh of the with the array of
the old toast you have and then you can
uh you know if you have five different
dose you can basically uh trigger all of
them or just provide you know like
number one to three or five and very
often you also want to you know
dynamically create them so that's that's
also possible let's see what what else
you can do so for the placement uh
you can uh you can
you can place them
uh using uh different css options uh so
for example middle center let's have a
look
and let's check this classes over here
so here you have this div class at
container and then you have
position absolute top 50 start 50. so
this will be the center
bottom
so yeah i can play with it and see how
to how to place them in
in the in the
in the place you actually want it to be
placed at your page
so yeah i mean that's uh that's really
really cool and let's go to methods
which are available so basically
obviously we can show we can we can hide
we can dispose if you don't want to get
this and get instance so uh yeah this
allows us to to just grab the uh the our
toast and then we can dynamically change
the content of it so technically you
could also have just one toast and and
keep on changing the content you want to
display to uh to the user so yeah i mean
really put your hands on it because it's
uh i think you're gonna use it a lot
sooner or later you will need this kind
of notification in your project if
you're building something more advanced
so this is a very very
handy tool to show user notification
like you know the facebook notification
or messenger or something you are seeing
this everywhere
okay now it's time to talk about the
nav bars so the navigation bar you can
see on many pages actually probably all
of them and they have it now what is so
cool about this navbar it is that it's
responsive by uh design by default um so
as soon as you shrink your screen to the
you know tablet to the mobile size it's
gonna
automatically collapse and then you can
use this so-called hamburger to
basically show or hide the content which
is there which
saves a lot space especially when it
comes to
mobile devices so uh let's have a look
how how does it work with bootstrap as
always bootstrap gives us like a basic
example which we can work on it's a
little bit complex so obviously we're
not going to go through all of
these classes because that's not the
point yeah to you know to to learn it uh
and know it by hard each and every line
uh that's not the point that's why we
have a docs for and uh so so so simply
uh
you can start by just grabbing the basic
nut bar and then do some adjustment to
it so that's what i did here i've got
the um i've got the uh the basic example
what i changed here um because i wanted
this to be dark so actually you know
what let me let me do this from scratch
again so let's get rid of this navbar
and just use
the basic one so this is the basic uh
nav bar and now we want to work on that
so first thing you could
or might want to change is whether you
want to have the full width or not you
can simply adjust it and change it by
changing this container either to fluid
or
if you keep the simple container then it
will get them to
to the center
so as you can see this is going like
here
and then if you get container it's more
to the center you can see it's clearly
on there on the bigger screen
so this is fluid
and this as
a normal container so if you want to
have these margins from the left and the
right then you should go with the
container one and that's what i'm gonna
stick to
now um let's say you want to have i want
to have a logo in here
very simple this is uh this is called
this is part which is called brand and
you can see this over here
and here is navbar brand right so this
is what we what we've got here we want
to change it just scroll it down and
find what you like so i would like to
have the image over here so i'm going to
add
this image over there so let's say it's
nav bar and i will have an image here
[Music]
and let's grab some
existing image because obviously i don't
have the bootstrap one here so let's
just replace it
with some logo and here it is uh let's
change the
uh color the size actually make it a
little bit slightly bigger okay i think
it looks better now maybe even
slightly
bigger right that could be
nice and now um i like the dark one so i
wanted to to do the dark one um so
simply scroll down until you find a
proper section here you have the color
scheme so probably that's what we are
looking for right and they have
different uh color scheme and then again
you can see you can notice um this
pattern here so um like with the all the
other components you just have to use
the proper class the color class so you
could use like a primary if you want to
have a primary color i will go with the
navbar dark and background dark so
if i go with the background dark only
let's change light to a dark you will
notice that i've got the dark navbar
however my links the text over here is
not really readable right so that's why
we need also this now bar dark so we
change this number light enough more
dark and that's gonna change also the
font color
okay now
secondly
now
if you don't want something in your
navbar simply just search for it
in here um i don't want to get this
disabled here and by the way if you are
not familiar and that might be a little
bit confusing right at the beginning
because there are many elements over
here uh i strongly encourage you to just
open the web developer tools and then go
to the elements and
try to
just search for element you're looking
for for example this one
right so this is the element and you can
for example press delete and see whether
you have the result you want right if
something if you if you do something
wrong
let's say you remove the wrong element
uh accidentally then nothing easier just
refresh the page and you're gonna get
back all the original html and the same
applies to whatever changes you want to
do so let's say
i want to have this one i'm going to
edit this
and i'm going to keep paste
and i got two dropdowns now right so now
you can play have a kind of sandbox um
which you can work on
so um yeah let's let me let me get rid
of
this disabled one because obviously i
want all my links to be active um
working in my navbar so that's cool
obviously i would could add some more
links here if i be uh doing the real
page um but that's
up to the use case you want to you want
to achieve
right you're going to find
many examples with the code um here
container so that's what we talked about
the placement all right so we have
option for the default one so the
default will basically um
if i'm gonna scroll down it's gonna
disappear
let's see actually let me add
let me add something at the bottom here
let's do a diff
and let's do some nasty thing that's
going to add
right so it disappears and then if we do
a fixed up
to our nav bar
so we have enough class
fixed up
it will just stick to the top so
regardless whether you're scrolling or
not it will be always there
um now because it's uh
because when we do it like this the
position is absolute so now this margin
doesn't work anymore we had a margin
over here on this element let me just
get rid of it so you will see there was
margin
here but it doesn't work for that so we
would also keep in mind to to to always
keep this margin from the top for each
and every element because otherwise null
bar will simply it will ignore the um
the margins which are the you can also
do the fixed bottom if you have it on
the bottom uh and stick it up so that it
will just stick to the top when you
start scrolling if it's not there right
so if for example this was our nav bar
and we started scrolling it will just
stick
go here and then stick at this
at this
height just to the top like the sticky
one
um yeah a lot of different options here
and um yeah i also wanted to show you
two more things um so one is this uh
external content option so if you for
some reason want to use this
functionality outside the
navbar itself you can do it bootstrap
give you this example very simple right
so we have just nav bar very simple one
as you can see not many not many classes
and the toddler over here
and
um what's going on here is that by using
this database target attribute
and using the same name as we have here
we are actually uh
combining this this this uh
this button this hamburger we are
connecting this to this element so it
knows which one to collapse if you have
more of them don't forget to use the
unique id's over there new component
introducing the strap five um off canvas
so the mini on the right the side menu
which you can also
use the same way as you do with the nub
bar so simply use the basic example and
then just start playing with this around
and changing adjusting uh to your needs
so
that's uh mostly about enough but um
probably sooner or later you're gonna
need that you're gonna use it um
for um for the page you will be building
or even the application right a lot of
the application uh use it um
like i know instagram and so on so so
take time to play with it um because
because you will be using this for sure
and now let's move to
navs navs and tabs so another category
of components which you can find which
i'm finding very useful and you can i
hope
you will also gonna like it so the bass
nav is um you know used for the
navigation um if you
want to have this um
um just the links right you can call it
just the menu on certain page so it's
not
strictly like a navbar it's not always
sticked it's something like you have
i don't know let's see on some pages
amazon.com for example
so as you can see this is the
navigation i'm talking about right the
basic navigation which is below the
enough bar over here so the base nav
so this is exactly the same uh what
you've got here by the way
we've been talking about different
components look how the amazon pages
built navbar so we just discussed this
enough over here
um slider or carousel so-called cards
we've been covering
a few minutes back
and yeah and then footer and some links
here so this is the basic setup which
you use and
which bootstrap offers you and with use
of them you can just recreate literally
any page in the internet so this is the
base navigation uh it's again very very
simple right you just have a basic
structure
and then you just use as many links as
you want however what is even more
interesting are so-called um tabs so
what the tabs are tabs are allows you to
change the content so these are our tabs
here let me show you and then how they
look in inspector
so
this is the entire
so this this is these are tabs and this
is the content tab content right it's
very small here obviously it could be
much much bigger uh it could be even
with the entire page right so it could
take the entire page and we could change
the content of the page
while changing to different tab this is
very handy you can see this a lot when
you work with
for example the admin panels right so
imagine this is the settings page and uh
you want to say i don't know like here
right so the some settings some general
settings some profile uh
adjustments uh and whatever right and
the same with the vertical one so
imagine this is some kind of you know
application and you can edit your
profile so here will be your personal
information here will be some um work
related info and so on so this is very
useful and you can see that this is very
dynamic right so you don't have to
reload the page you can have all of that
on the single page and then again if you
go to uh to this
um
and scroll to the
proper section
you will
get this
taps right home profile contact um very
simple usage all right so we have two
sections here we have a pills
which are here one two three and then we
have this uh kind of placeholders so we
have three of them as well and now what
we have to do so this is the content
going here uh what you need to do you
need to just make sure
that you have the corresponding
um corresponding uh ids over here so
look this is the home top right so this
is you this is called home so we have
this area labeled by home
and the id is pills home
and this um yeah let me actually show
you this in this source code it's going
to be much
better visible so let's go to our tabs
so this is the example
all right so this is pills home
and this builds home
corresponds with this button here so
it
has to match this database target so hit
this target
and
this has to be the same so if you are
just adding new one let's let's add
something new here
so contact tab
let's add new one and let's call it um
i don't know
maybe just other so
i'll just change this to other
also this one
right and now we need to have the new
enough item here
so i'm gonna make a copy of this and now
what we need to do here is we need to
change this to other
other so this id has to current
correspond
this is the other and this is obviously
other
and that's how we get the new tab
in the
in our page right very simple very very
easy and exactly the same way if you
want to work with the vertical which
example you've got over here
okay now i would like to talk a little
bit about something which is not
specifically a bootstrap component
because it's a separate project however
is created by the same team and i'm
thinking about the icon so if you go to
the extend and icons you're gonna see
this page uh where you're gonna see a
the list of alternative options so if
you're familiar with fondo some or this
octi icons or whatever icons you've been
using there are some options here
so
you know feel free to to use them
however bootstrap recently came up with
their own set of icons and i really like
it i feel like they are really really um
yeah good uh looking icons and what's
most important there are like 1500s
already so so it's a lot and i'm pretty
sure that most of the icons you might be
looking uh for to use within your
project inside your project you're gonna
find it here so uh how to use it it's
very simple uh you have all icons listed
here so if you're looking for something
let's say wi-fi you simply just search
for it and then you choose and click on
it and then you're gonna get uh three
options um
first you're gonna have examples so
you're gonna see you're gonna have a
preview how it looks like and how you
can use it with the sample examples of
like you know how it's going to look in
the button or in the input
now what you can do now to use it you
can either download this like svg so
simply hit
and save and that's gonna save you the
uh the image um and
then you just load it uh as you would do
with any kind of an image you use on the
page uh other option which we're gonna
cover later is to use it as icon but
then you need to include
the phone the css for that um i want to
show you this before we move to to the
icon font so this is simply the html
this is svg so this is like a row code
of this icon so this path is basically
diff you know the svg consists of this
lines paths and this is just you know
these are the the points uh so the
browser now know how to uh draw this
icon so it's very simple to use because
you just copy this
and then you simply paste it
and here it is this is our icon right
you can change the size
to something bigger let's say 50
using this width and height properties
or you can also do it like you would do
with any other html element so you can
just create some
class let's say icon and then create
some custom style for it so i'm going to
call it icon
and define a width
of 200 pixel and that's gonna work as
well now coming back to the installation
so the icon installation
simply hit the install button that's
going to scroll down to this section and
as you can see there are
many options how you can install it you
can do npm
you can download the entire entire
library or you can use the cdn so i'm
going to use this one
so let's just paste it in our head tag
and now coming back to icon let's grab
something
we can simply just copy this icon font
this i
tag and paste it here down below or next
to our icon it's small um obviously
so again how to change the size you can
do it with styles so set the font
because it's like font so just send the
font size to whatever it is i know 50
pixels the same or 200
you can also change
font color obviously
you just work with it like you would be
doing with the
any other font and as i said i mean you
know i think you have
pretty much uh
every icon you could possibly need in a
project like so you know some hamburgers
over here
yeah i mean just give a try and i really
like this and i really like having those
icons
and everything within the same ecosystem
of bootstrap
okay so now let's talk about um so
important components that bootstrap
finally decide to provide a separate
section for it uh within their docs
because recently in the bootstrap 4
they didn't have it and now we have like
the separate uh category for forms so um
yeah and bootstrap as um like with the
other components it's making
um our life easier um by um supplying us
with the certain classes which makes our
inputs and and other
form controls simply look better and uh
let's uh yeah let's see what we have
here and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna build some uh some contact form uh
so uh we we're not gonna go uh into each
and every um control because that would
take like you know probably a few hours
just to just to cover all of that but
we're gonna build like the um
very
common contact form and then i'm gonna
show you a couple more examples of what
you can do also with the form so um yeah
let's jump into it uh let's open this in
live server
and now what we're going to do we're
going to start with
some
text let's say so
let's have text center and inside it i
want to have h2 get in touch
so that's uh yeah that's gonna be uh our
heading and then let's have p
uh lead
something like i know um questions
do not hesitate to contact us
okay
now
let's add some row
and we're gonna also add justify
content center so it will be always
centered and let's also add some margins
here
and
we're gonna add
some
forms but before we're going to add
forms let's add
also some column
so
there's going to be large
there's going to be 6 on
the large screens and on the smaller one
uh it's gonna just take the full wave
and inside it let's start creating our
form so i'm gonna deform i wanna leave
the action empty for now because we are
not
adding any logic to it we will just
creating the frontend part for it and
let's start with the label so
if we do a simple label for email
because we're gonna that's what we're
gonna start with
uh it gonna looks like this and let's
add input type email
okay and then let's give id
email
and what we can also have we can have
placeholder obviously
something like
my
email.com so this is
how
it looks like uh just by using the
normal forms and loading bootstrap css
however we can we can make it even
better because if we add class
form
label to our label and we're gonna add
class
form
control
that's what's gonna happen
and
yeah let me let me add
show you a few more examples and then
we're gonna
also talk about a variation you can have
with
with bootstrap
forms and inputs so let's add another
one and let's let me just copy paste
this one because we will have it for
name
and name
and
name
and then let's say i know our example
take it
okay we're not
gonna bother with the spacing here we're
gonna we're gonna fix it uh later uh so
we have two inputs and now
add some select and so
we're gonna add again label
and that's gonna be for subject of our
uh email
and
we're gonna add again class
form label
and then we're going to go to subject
okay and now we have select so just the
normal select
except for the fact that we're gonna
add
actually we don't need this name but uh
i'll just keep it
um class
form
select
and then we're gonna add some options
here so option
and it's gonna be let's say uh pricing
oh it should be
pricing
let's make copy of it what else we could
have here possibly
technical
and some others
or general
whatever you want to call it
okay so this is our this is our
select now and if we want to have some
default value selected then we just add
this
selected to the given option and it's
gonna work like a chart and finally
let's add some text area so the user
could write us some some message so
again label
and that's going to be our query
and so
write
message
and then we're going to have a text area
and obviously whoops text
area
uh it's gonna be query query
calls row so we're gonna set it to
default and but we're gonna add
class
form control
okay so this is it maybe a little bit
uh smaller
whoops
meant to be smaller not bigger
and then finally let's add maybe some
div
with text center and we're going to add
some button here so button
it's type it's gonna be submit
and class is gonna be btn i know btn
primary let's use primary
send
okay oh it didn't work
text center if i only can't spell it
properly
um yeah so that's that's it and it's
it's um yeah it could be a working form
however let's tune it a little bit um
with bootstrap 5 we can easily
create a pretty nice
pretty nice effect on
something called floating labels so i'm
going to show you that in a second um
just one more thing here is that we
could also have a placeholder i believe
right something
yeah this is it and it's going to
disappear when we start typing that's
cool however
if we want to use this floating
then
i'm going to get rid of it i'm going to
show you
a nice trick i believe which you can use
when working with bootstrap forms so
let's do
form
floating
and then let's do some
spacing my5
and now what we're going to do here
we're going to just put it this
inside div
and
what happens now is that we don't need
this um
we don't need this oh actually we didn't
even have this
we didn't even have this class here so
we were missing this class
form label which should be there
however when you work with floating we
don't you you should remove it and then
let's change the order of it and so the
text area comes first and now see what's
gonna
happen then this is
let's do
uh let's do this like that style
and then the height
of 200 pixel
okay
and now a little bit smaller 150
and then we have
form floating text area
and it doesn't work because
we are actually
missing this placeholder i believe
yeah it can be empty
for some reason
yeah so
now you can see you have this nice
floating label over here and we can
actually do pretty much the same with
our inputs so let's do this now uh let's
use it for name
okay so then what we have to do is
we have to switch our label
with the input that goes down below
and now it's working fine see so you can
also achieve this very interesting
effect on your inputs simply by using
this um
this div with the form of floating class
um yeah so this is it this is how you
actually work with it obviously there
are more um
inputs here you have a range option
and you have a steppers and and you have
input groups i think this is also
interesting where you can combine
input with other elements
so i prepared for you
some examples over here so uh you can
examine that
by yourself and play with it so if you
want to play with some check boxes uh
you have new really nice options like
this intermediate checkbox right so we
have like checked unchecked and this one
is intermediate step
available
some wrench some file upload
and
and few more examples also with the
validation that's also interesting
because you can easily add um the
validation messages to the uh to your
inputs and then that's also fairly
simple with the uh
with the bootstrap because as you can
see bootstrap comes with predefined
labels you just specify that it's
invalid check
right for the input and then you say
what you want to what you want to write
so you have this
invalid feedback
right so this you must agree before
submitting
and you also have this positive feedback
so
here valid feedback which you use
together with along with the input
and this
this obviously gives a user a nice
positive feedback he knows that the
message is that that everything was fine
and you know for example the password he
provided
was strong enough
okay so we covered a lot of different
components
which bootstrap offers us
let's see what we haven't covered yet
and which we're not going to do in this
video because it would take definitely
too much time but
these components are not that common but
they will still can be useful for you so
for example the accordion right so the
kind of collapse the difference between
collapse and accordion is that accordion
by default works like
at this which means that you can have
only one
active item right so we i cannot expand
two at the same time
i just have to use to one and then again
this is pretty much simple i mean there
is a lot of code over here but obviously
i think um you can easily
play with it and understand how does it
go because you can see that there's
accordion items
which are recurring elements right and
then if you want to just add or remove
it you simply copy paste add new one and
then you have
you change the heading
and then the content
uh what else we have here we talk about
others uh badges
you also
we often use them however again nothing
fancy i think nothing complex here is
just the spawn with the class batch and
that's gonna give you uh this look you
will see this uh being used for example
in the notification like here or like
this
so pretty pretty straightforward
breadcrumbs again if you want to show
user where are you now what are you
doing um i mean if you are going further
into for example documentation like here
you could show it uh that we are at
components and then breadcrumbs uh maybe
with two levels it doesn't make much
sense but for example here if you go to
variables maybe that would
make more sense for that
um we we talked about the buttons um
you can obviously
[Music]
use button groups as well if you want to
work with them so if you won't have to
move
multiple buttons combine into each other
we talked about the carousel
dropdowns we didn't talk about that
specifically but
uh yeah they were pretty much the same
as you've seen in the navbar um so that
allows you to
show um you know more info on demand
right so you can have
some info in the nav bar and then if you
want to have more links you can just add
more and more drop downs list groups
pretty much straightforward
similar to cards and panels we've seen
so the panels but they're just
they're just just um
either using uh lists
and that's how you that's how they look
like
models this is also very
very
interesting and important uh component
so let's have a look at this a little
bit closer
so again mechanic is pretty uh pretty
much the same so first you just copy the
model into your page
so let's add it here
to our body
so this is this is this model and it's
not going to be visible
until we actually
fire this off so we would have to add
the
this
piece of javascript to it so this will
fire when we click on the button so
let's add this button over here
okay
and we will need
to
actually use
this
and this uh yeah i copied i copied this
model and this is different example the
ids are different but it's triggered by
a
data
target database target so that you need
to make sure that this matches so you
have this example model here and we have
example model here over there
so then again for the model itself
you have header you have body and you
have footer so
pretty much like we've been doing with
cards so you can design it as you want
you have different buttons over here
it's dismissible and then you can simply
just add the trigger it is possible also
to use javascript for that
so
if you want
you can you can
do it from javascript and you're going
to find more information how to do it
here and change the configuration
whether you want to have a backup light
like this
shadow
in the back this is this gray which kind
of makes your eye focusing on the model
so all of that can be controlled from uh
from the javascript um
and as always there are like different
options because you can have like full
screen models uh you can have
large models small models extra large so
you can you can decide um and work on uh
different sizing and also
also when you want to display whether
it's on the center or maybe to the right
and so one you can embed different um
different things like you know i can
embed for example the youtube
videos so a lot of
possibilities to choose from and finally
obviously uh when you have uh
and models you can also uh use different
methods to show toggle right so i can
also change it from show to hidden
hidden to show show hide
and dispose and so on and so we talked
about nasa nav bars of canvas we also
covered um so uh yeah popover this is
also interesting this is also why we
actually used um what we actually used
popper in the first place the popovers
are pretty similar
um
to
the tooltips right so let's see two tips
first
so the tooltips you know
when you hover over a certain element
you can get you can show the user a
certain
tooltip with extra information
which will make this easier for them to
you know get more familiar how to use
your website and when it comes to
popover it's pretty much the same
however you need to click to toggle
return so if you click on it it's gonna
appear and it stays there and if you
want to
hide it you need to unclick it
and you can decide whether you want to
whether you want user actually to
specifically unclick on the button or
you want him to unclick anywhere
finally
spinners and scroll spy so let's start
with spinners this is what you use when
you want to
load something right so you just use it
and then usually what we do
in such case we are actually
uh it doesn't work because i put it
probably inside
yeah inside model so let me get it out
of model
yeah so this is the this is the spinner
so you use it when you want to show that
something is loading you can use it and
combine it with for example uh buttons
right so no one either click on
something and waiting for the feedback
it's just giving him more information
that he's actually waiting for something
and and and the page is doing some logic
in and behind uh and then once it's done
you simply just use your js um to change
it uh to to hide this element or to
replace with something else um
progress so the progress bars uh yeah
pretty straightforward here so depending
on the value you set and
in this attribute value now
it will basically
fill up the progress bar
to show the current status you can add
labels like percentage you can change
colors
and there are obviously different um
the color version
of
of this
as well as the you know multiple bars so
if you want uh to show uh like you know
for example that certain amount consists
of three different values and then you
can uh use different colors to show it
and finally uh scrolls by so uh this is
this is also uh very useful uh
which you can also see very often on the
pages for example we are using this at
our mdbootstrap.com if you go and check
any kind of navigation we are using the
scroll spine over here so this uh gives
user you know a nice feeling where he
she exactly is now
while using this documentation uh so
yeah this is also handy it's not that
common it's it's a little bit more
complex but uh sometimes you might want
to use it like here you have a
navigation however you don't know where
exactly you are obviously i mean you can
match it here but this visual
hint it's it's it's always useful and
you can see it uh especially when it
comes to you know technical
documentation
okay so we cover a lot of components uh
obviously there are some more uh to go
through uh however we're not gonna do it
in this video but let's wrap it up and
actually use whatever we learn
in this course to build a proper website
so um i'm gonna start with this this
this template where we have the
bootstrap css and js loaded and let's
start building our page so i'm going to
start with the header and inside this
header i would like to have some nav bar
so let's find it out let's go to
components and then
check for naf bar
and i'm going to grab the basic example
and i'm gonna start with it it's gonna
be good
for the starting
point and i want to get rid of this
disabled and i want to
let's see what else want to i want to
make it dark actually well so
now let's start with getting this
disabled out
and let's see how we can change the
color here it is so i want to have
navbar dark and navbar
and background
dark
yeah this looks cool to me and i think
that i might want to use container
instead of
the container fluid which will basically
center my content
okay so uh let's now do something which
is called
jumbotron it's not there in a in the
bootstrap five
however in the bootstrap form bootstrap
used to had something like this
in the past so just like a catchy um
element which we can use to you know to
um catch someone attention and i would
like to use it here on the page um so
let's go and do some
let's do some grid so i'm gonna do the
main part so i'm gonna just do the
semantically
correct and then let's do container
and inside this container let's have a
row
and oh
let's have a row and then inside it i
would like to have a call
md7
and then call md5 so i don't want to
have them to be equal
i want them
however i still want them to sum up up
to 12. so
in the left side i would like to have
some image
with obviously image fluid class
and let's grab something from big sum
which you already know oops i need to
put it here
uh so we have it here on we already see
that we are missing some spacing so
let's add it class m y five
okay
so here we have image uh if we change id
we're gonna
get some other image so you can play
with it and search for something which
will
suit you most
and
as far as the right part is concerned i
would stick it to some some catchy
tagline so let's have h1
and then let's say this is our tagline
okay
and within this tagline let's
also add for
example some
paragraph we need to get it
a little bit
uh down
and let's add some lorem i know 30 will
that be sufficient
yeah i think that's that's okay
uh it can be too long um obviously
normally we would use some catchy text
over here it couldn't be too long uh
because user need to read it quite fast
and then let's add some button so we're
going to have a button
so the type is button
and the class
is
btn
and then btn primary
and then margin top let's say five
and then let's say i know call to action
we want user to do something here
yeah maybe this is too much how about
three
yeah i guess that's better
and i would still
do it
i know let's do this class
mt5
yeah i think
now it looks cool
so this blue color responds with the
image so yeah i really like it now let's
um let's add some call to action here
now um
so
i'm going to show you how to create
actually
uh the
um
component which is not during bootstrap
like we did with jumbotron just to show
you that bootstrap is not only about the
components it's also about the youtubes
and classes which you can use
to create and to design
your own um ideas so uh yeah let's add
another row over here
and now within this row let's just add
the full call to be semantically correct
and then um let's do something like that
i want to have bg secondary color
um
bg secondary
okay and let's add some text
here lorem
10 let's see
okay yeah it doesn't look good yet but
we'll
make it beautiful soon so we've got the
um kind of dark background so probably
it will be wise to change text to white
or something lighter
okay
and now see uh what i'm gonna do i'm
actually on a also wrap it up
as a card button so i'm using
the bootstrap
component here
and
i'm gonna do
some spacing q so my5
as well as
py4
and let's also add card
okay and i want this everything to be
text centered
and yeah i think i think it's okay um
perhaps even a little smaller
yeah something like this would do
um yeah
and maybe even
i think that that looks cool now um now
let's add some
cards here
[Music]
to uh show our latest blog posts
so i'm gonna add another row
and now let's see what we've got here so
let's get back to cards
and um
either we're gonna use three cards with
an image so
we can
copy the basic example all
[Music]
or
we would go with the
this
card group
so i don't know which one i like more
i think we haven't done current group
yet so let's do card group
in here
however i would like to
now we don't have the one with the
button
so uh
let's do we're gonna add this manually
so let's do this here
i have a call and now
let's put it
let's place it like this and now let's
um let's add some images so
i'm just gonna replace this one where it
source
with number
200
201
and then 202
so this is going to give me nice images
and let's just add
a button so again you can type
everything yourself or you can just copy
paste an existing
sample and
let's i know should we put it above
or should we put it um
below so let's try it below so i will do
now multi-cursor so i'm just gonna click
here here
and there with my alt pressed and now i
can type
in
um
in a few door in a few places at the
same time so i'm gonna add text center
and inside this i'm gonna put
our
hour button and i'm going to change it
to read
more and actually you know what i just
did it
that's the a
because we need this to be a hyperlink
and then
now i will just
i'm not sure if you can see this clearly
i'm just editing this three lines at the
same time read
more yeah and this will go here and
actually i think i should do it
i should do it other way around so i
should
and actually you know what let's get rid
of this we don't i think user is not
interested in whether it's been updated
or not
three minutes uh because it's a blog
post maybe if we were doing the magazine
that would be uh more important and you
know what as well i don't want this to
be centered to be honest when i look at
it now so let's just
get rid of it
and stick to that the basic stuff okay
that's cool and now finally i'm gonna do
um
i'm gonna do some shortcut here i'm just
gonna get the form so let's have this
form here from here
and let's
actually i want to have this container
so uh
yeah i will need this row where are you
hold on i might i can't see
oh here it collapse
and now let's let's cut this one
and let's change to the landing
who why i need to find my row now so
this is main this is number row number
one
row number two
row number three
and
is it
yeah this is the one
except for the fact that we need some
spacing here as well
okay and finally let's go and find some
bootstrap five footer
this is one of the option um
but let's just
let's just do something like
sticky footer
okay
so
this is footer
i'm gonna get
this footer
and i'm gonna go
and add it here
as a footer
and obviously i'm gonna change it to
dark
and
let's see
yeah so this is our sticky footer at the
bottom
and then we would do something like
copyrights
https mdbootstrap.commd
bootstrap.com
cool
so
um yeah maybe this is not the most
complex site you've ever seen but i
think we've created this like in what
um it was
10 minutes perhaps
i think it's even less so
i hope that i just gave you this idea
how quickly you can really prototype
your pages with the use of the bootstrap
components
and you can really really nicely
just organize everything and because
obviously you could write all of that by
yourself but a it would take much much
longer b i mean you would be actually
reinventing the wheel so you would be
fighting with you know making this
making this
responsive uh and this obviously by
default is responsive uh so it will
adjust the screen it will look um
perfectly on each and every screen uh
you have a you have also scripts here so
you know to create this drop down you
can do it yourself but it's there it's
been tested by millions of users so
there's no point doing this uh so
i hope you enjoy you enjoyed
this um
tutorial
okay so finally i wanted to show you the
last thing is how you can easily publish
your page so what you have to do to
publish your page you simply open the
command line i have the one which is
built in in visual studio code but you
could also use a
command line from windows or terminal
from mac os whichever you are using
navigate to the folder
of your choice and then i'm going to go
to cd
landing because this is where the uh the
page we uh
we just created and the free code camp
is just a generic folder with all the
subfolders there is no index.html file
so i i will need this index.html file or
actually landing
to be there and actually you know what
let's let's also rename it into
index.html so as you know then the
browser will know uh that this is um
this is the entry file and then what you
have to do is just simply type mdb
publish and that's going to ask you
whether you want to use npm or yarn i'm
going to stick with the npm it's going
to ask about the name so let's do the
free
code camp
bootstrap five let's say
and few more options i'm gonna just
accept the default ones i'm gonna hit
enter and what you're gonna see is that
this is gonna be updated within uh just
seconds and you're gonna see the url
over here when you click it boom your
patch has been just deployed to the
server and this is uh this is there
this is secured with ssl and it's
absolutely free if you don't have it
yet simply navigate to mdbgo.com
and there's where you can find the
installation procedure so it's you have
to install this mdb tool so you'll be
able and to do mdb
um
in your command line so npm install
minus gmdbcli and just create the free
account so you would be able to do mdb
publish on your account with your url